merci Thomas d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure sénateur
socialiste du Val-d'Oise vice-président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
ici au Sénat on va parler de la loi de
programmation militaire dans quelques
instants vous allez chez
particulièrement ce dossier au Sénat
mais d'abord évidemment la réforme des
retraites on l'a vu Elisabeth borde qui
consulte donc les groupes parlementaires
sur le calendrier parlementaire des
prochains mois les parlementaires
socialistes n'ont pas c'est
consultations est-ce que c'est pas une
erreur pourquoi refuser de voir la
première ministre d'abord ce que on peut
noter c'est que il faut le réaffirmer
que les Français et les syndicats les
syndicats totalement les Français très
très largement contre cette réforme le
mot réforme je crois de trop contre la
retraite à 64 ans et ses dégâts dans la
vie des français des Français est-ce que
nous comprenons pas c'est pourquoi alors
que l'Inter syndical a demandé un
rendez-vous auprès d'un public n'est pas
reçu et ce qu'on dit également c'est que
par rapport à Madame borne c'est qu'il
faut d'abord qu'elle reçoive les
syndicats qu'elle échange et qu'elle
entendent ce qu'ils ont à dire nous ce
que nous avons décidé c'est
effectivement Olivier fort se rendra un
truc comme promis secrétaire au
rendez-vous ce qu'on veut dire par là
c'est que le beaucoup de on va faire
autre chose on peut pas parler du
calendrier législatif
c'est on c'est un jeu c'est un leurre
qu'est-ce qui se passe concrètement
au-delà du projet que tout le monde a
condamné et que nous avons je vous
rappelle un recours auprès du Conseil
consuel et la demande d'un référendum
comme dos d'ailleurs j'ai noté que
d'autres le demander également comme
notamment le président du groupe ça
c'est un premier sujet ce qu'on dit
également c'est que est-ce qu'il est
démontré c'est que ce gouvernement là
n'a plus de majorité il avait majorité
relative assemblée il a perdu cela on
l'a vu bon donc on nous dit on va
refaire un calendrier parlementaire mais
enfin pourquoi faire pour dire quoi pour
élargir la majorité qu'on augmente le
prix d'un public nous ne sommes pas
candidat à rentrer dans cette majorité
nous sommes contre cette majorité
relative qui est celle d'aujourd'hui de
renaissance d'horizon
cortex puisque c'est aussi l'objectif de
ces consultations
un peu d'histoire en 2017 Emmanuel
Macron avait dit je ferai la droite et
la gauche certillon cru moi jamais bon
certains y ont cru finalement 5 ans
après vous avez vu il a juste été de
plus en plus à droite et symbolique avec
la suppression de l'ISF et on fait payer
les appels pour les plus pauvres ça
c'est le Macron 1 le Macron 2 c'est quoi
c'est après législatif de juin 2022 il
nous avait dit et Madame Macron et
Madame borne également les deux avaient
dit on va regarder texte par textes
comment construire vous l'avez vu sur la
retraite la majorité des parties des
syndicats à son compte il y a n'écoute
pas donc aujourd'hui on a déjà deux fois
le coup de on va entendre on va
travailler ensemble ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que en fait Emmanuel Macron
considère que même si les minorités à
l'Assemblée il minérateur au Sénat il
doit être majoritaire à la fin du jeu ça
ne s'installe pas une discussion ça ne
marche pas donc nous ce qu'on dit c'est
que le premier sujet aujourd'hui c'est
cette année autre sujet
vous regardez les prix j'écoutais
notamment une radio une grande radio
matinale qui est un panier un panier
entre guillemets de la radio scénario
public on peut le dire France Info et on
peut le dire et donc c'est plus
quasiment plus 13 % sur le panier de ce
panier là et les Français ils ont
discuté pourquoi il n'y a pas le chèque
alimentation pourquoi le chèque Amazon
n'est pas arrivé on l'a demandé encore
au Sénat la semaine dernière partie
ricosique mon collègue socialiste de la
Sarre il y a pas de réponse vous voyez
bien c'est climat social inflation
inquiétude sur l'avenir des Françaises
et Français qui ont discuté à manger et
le ballon ne répond pas donc oui nous
demandons-nous aujourd'hui des mesures
sur le sur le climat social nous avons
fait des propositions sur les salaires
ça n'a pas été entendu sur l'inflation
ça n'a pas attendu donc on veut que les
syndicats soient reçus avant ils seront
ceux demain est-ce que si la première
ministre vous invite la semaine
prochaine vous irez mais on va voir ce
qu'elle a à dire si elle leur dit au
syndicat vous venez mais vous n'avez pas
le droit de parler de retraite ça ne
fonctionne pas non plus de problème
notre problème à nous c'est pas de
savoir si bon on y va pas vous voyez
bien que la situation de crise dans
lequel est ce pays il y a une crise
économique il y a une crise sociale dans
un climat et on l'évoquera tout à
l'heure de crise internationale de crise
climatique bah on peut pas juste dire on
passe au sujet suivant non aujourd'hui
les millions de Français qui sont dans
la rue depuis des mois et des mois qui
vont manifester encore qui perd chaque
fois qui manifeste des journées de
salaire 90 euros 100 euros ça dépend des
salaires on peut pas leur dire juste
allez maintenant on passe à autre chose
non parce que leur vie concrète elle est
impactée notre vie concrète elle sera
impactée par la réforme des repas donc
vous dites comme Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe unionchantiste qui
lui est favorable à la réforme il faut
écouter les syndicats réformistes il
faut briser la glace avec la CFDT a
raison de dire cela mais pas que la
cfdtif c'est l'Inter syndicale vous
allez être un secret qui fonctionne ne
cherchons pas diviser il faut retirer ce
projet de retraite donc vous êtes sur le
retrait pas sur pause comme le dit alors
Laurent Berger si si à la fin il y a pas
ça sera très bien aussi nous savez on
est cohérent nous les socialistes nous
avons déposé une censure pour que le
texte soit censuré et nous avons
dépensément avec d'autres forces de
gauche pour un référendum initiatique
partagé par le partager donc à part cela
nous sommes cohérents nous c'est ce que
nous demandons parce que c'est ce que
demandent les Français également un mot
sur un autre sujet mercredi Gérald
Darmanin sera auditionné devant le
Parlement sur la gestion du maintien de
l'ordre lors des mobilisations quand
attendez-vous de cette audition
je crois que chacun tu vois des images
d'abord la violence qu'il y a je
rappelle que les manifestations jusqu'à
jusqu'au 49-3 enfin je fais pas de lien
mais cette période là jusqu'à après
l'adoption par 49-3 du texte des
manifestations sont bien passées depuis
il y a des soucis plus également ce qui
s'est passé autour des bassines la
question du maintien de l'ordre je crois
que c'est normal que le Parlement puisse
avoir des échanges réguliers avec le
ministre concerné sur mainteneur donc il
faut que là je sais que la défense aux
ai droit à édité 90k mais il y a aussi
1000 policiers gendarmes qui ont été
blessés il faut donc les soutenir aussi
et d'abord je dis moi je suis pour
effectivement mais je suis pour une un
maintien de l'ordre de la sécurité dans
le pays parce que la sécurité c'est la
première des libertés elle a attendu par
tous nos français surtout quand on voit
ce qui se passe à Marseille autre
endroit donc moi je trouve ça juste
normal que dans son rôle de Parlement le
Sénat auditionne entendre s'il y a des
choses à dire quelque part le disent
s'il y a des propositions à faire pour
d'amélioration mais je crois que la
doctrine de maintien de l'or parce que
c'est ça donc il s'agit moi je vise la
doctrine la doterie il est normal qu'on
puisse la réviser qu'on puisse échanger
dessus et communiste puisse expliquer je
crois que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
autre sujet Emmanuel Macron a reçu hier
les membres de la Convention citoyenne
sur la fin de vie qui leur ont remis
leur conclusion ces membres demande la
mise en place d'une aide active à mourir
donc d'aller plus loin que la loi
Claisse Leonetti le chef de l'État n'a
pas franchement tranché mais il a promis
un projet de loi d'ici la fin de l'été
c'est une bonne chose moi je suis un
acte un soutien de cette cause depuis
très longtemps mais si je peux me
permettre d'un mot d'abord le souci que
nous avons en France c'est que on la fin
de vie et compliquée parfois très
douloureuse et on a un problème de fin
de vie en France la fin de vie c'est on
le voit c'est tout le débat qui est sur
les EHPAD c'est tous les gens comment
ils continuent après à rester chez eux
avec quel soin quelle disposition et ça
c'est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de service public notamment sur ces
questions là et on voit bien que c'est
hors de prix qui qu'on connaît le sujet
c'est hors de prix pour les Français et
c'est très donc très compliqué donc là
il y a un vrai fort à faire et il y a un
deuxième jambe j'ai envie de dire c'est
la très fin de vie c'est là où se la
question des derniers jours derniers
instants et c'est vrai qu'en France on
vit on vieillit mal et on meurt mal donc
dans ce cas là moi je suis favorable
bien évidemment à aller plus loin que la
loi scless Tony qui est déjà un vrai
progrès il faut le rappeler et donc moi
d'ailleurs j'ai fait des débats sur ce
plateau même moi je suis favorable et je
le dis il faut pas opposer les options
moi je suis pour que chaque français
quand il est concerné par les cartes qui
seront listés puis savoir la possibilité
d'avoir les soins palliatifs je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
quand vous êtes en dehors de quelques
grandes métropoles donc c'est pas
acceptable et le plan je rappelle au
présent qui est un plan qui existe déjà
tous les cinq ans donc la question c'est
surtout comment il fonctionne comment
les comment ça n'est pas elle n'est pas
nécessaire
il n'y a pas suffisamment de moyens pour
faire que partout sur le territoire
français je deviens partout sur le
territoire l'Hexagone mais également
dans l'outre-mer en plus avoir des
unités soit dans les hôpitaux soit à la
maison il faut faire les deux en
parallèle il faut renforcer les moyens
des soins palliatif mais il faut aller
plus loin
pour une élective à mourir qui se passe
par le suicide assisté qui passe par
l'euthanasie en sachant que les ce que
j'ai entendu tous ceux qui souhaitent
nous on a déposer au groupe socialiste
une proposition de lois ici qui a été
rejetée d'ailleurs tous ceux qui sont
les acteurs sur ce dossier savent que à
la fois la question de choix la
vérification des médecins là où j'étais
tout ça c'est ce que nous portons depuis
toujours tant mieux tant mieux dans la
loi il faut laisser le choix entre
l'euthanasie et le suicide assisté
est-ce qu'il faut privilégier une des
deux options et je crois que c'est
liberté qui a été frétée sur devise je
crois qu'il faut laisser aux français
quand ils sont concernés la liberté de
choisir quelle est leur fin de vie
parfois elles peuvent vous dire ils
peuvent nous dire légaliser le suicide
ils peuvent vous dire par exemple je
vais faire le temps après la vie
finalement non je vais faire ou
inversement il faut les laisser choisir
donc ça ça s'appelle la liberté
l'égalité c'est que partout vous êtes
vous avez différentes options ouvertes
et la fraternité je pense que la société
doit comprendre quelles sont les choix
et permettre aux uns aux autres je crois
que c'est il faut il faut assez simple
après moi je comprends qu'il y a des
gens pour que ça chope je rencontre des
gens qui me disent pourquoi ne sont pas
d'accord et j'entends leur position mais
je leur dis il ne s'agit pas d'obliger
les gens il s'agit de permettre à ceux
qui sont concernés par des Indiens
curables par des douleurs atroces dont
on connaît la fin de pouvoir j'ai envie
de dire choisir leur fin une jeune femme
j'ai envie de dire la fin la plus
apaisée possible apaisée possible donc
c'est ça
tout le monde le dit on vieillit mal et
on meurt mal donc je crois qu'il y a
deux choses à faire majeur je l'ai dit
sur la le vieillissement le grand loi
promise plutôt qu'une endroit c'est des
mesures concrètes aujourd'hui on
vieillit mal en France ça coûte
extrêmement cher il y a une vraie
différence en fonction de vos revenus et
vos territoires et puis on meurt mal
exactement donc je crois que ces deux
aspects qui doivent être complémentaires
et qui sont une priorité aujourd'hui je
crois non des médecins pour qu'il n'ait
pas trop de responsabilité et de il y a
peut-être aussi une meilleure formation
sur la formation il y a bien sûr bien
sûr vous avez raison de le rappeler sur
il faut aussi garantir la sécurité
juridique de l'ensemble des personnels
qui concernent cela d'abord parce que
ils font l'entendre ils sont formés pour
protéger pour guérir pour permettre la
vie donc j'entends que pour soi
complexée compliqué donc il faut les
protéger également parce que sinon ils
peuvent pas eux se retrouver ensuite
mise en accusation voilà donc ça c'est
toutes des éléments donc c'est pour ça
qu'un projet de loi me semble la bonne
option puisque ça permet d'avancer
encore si j'ai bien compris il faut
essayer de se mettre d'accord sur ce
qu'il y a dans le projet loi puisque le
président dit on va mettre le
gouvernement les assemblées donc il faut
maintenant avancer il a pas vraiment
donné
sa position
il y a une chose qui est simple je ne
sais pas quels sont les ministres qui
vont porter cela et qui sera désigné au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée mais moi si j'ai
tout autour de la table à mon avis il
peut pas dire au ministre vous en pensez
quoi ça peut pas être un échange et un
marchandage un moment il y a bien une
discussion de fond donc soit c'est sur
la base du rapport de la convention
citoyenne auquel cas il faut le dire
après on travaille dans ce cadre-là en
tout cas moi si je devais travailler je
un conseil que je n'aurais c'est de
partir de la convention et de dire à
partir de là on construit un texte et
finalement effectivement il y aura puis
après il va parlementaires il y aura de
la parlementaire mais je dis voilà donc
il y a des gens qui sont pour eux et des
gens qui sont contre je crois que les
Français sont majoritairement favorables
d'après les différentes études mais il
faut aussi entendre les voix d'essayer
de ceux qui posent des questions parfois
d'ailleurs même philosophiques tout cela
parler de la loi de programmation
militaire qui est donc présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres on
va avoir le sous-sol les détails avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Alex
pusard
[Musique]
à l'aise donc être présenté aujourd'hui
en conseil des ministres une loi qui
augmente largement le budget des armées
dans les prochaines années ah oui un
budget de 413 milliards d'euros pour nos
armées sur la période 2024 2030 c'est un
niveau historique avec une augmentation
progressive chaque année du budget des
de la défense dans la continuité du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 le budget des armées sur une année
s'élevé à 32 milliards d'euros en 2023
il est déjà à 44 milliards d'euros et en
2030 il sera porté à 69 milliards
d'euros le gouvernement qui prévoit
d'ailleurs une rallonge budgétaire cette
année 20,5 milliards d'euros pour
amortir les effets de l'inflation sur
nos armées orianes et c'est quoi va
servir tout cet argent et bien répondre
à des urgences à des priorités l'urgence
c'est la guerre en Ukraine la France va
d'ailleurs livrer un système de défense
solaire à l'armée ukrainienne pour
protéger par exemple la ville de Kiev
contre les baumes bombardements russes
autre priorité la modernisation de notre
dissuasion nucléaire et également la
lutte anti drone alors c'est priorités
elles ont été expliquées dimanche par le
ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
dans une interview au Parisien il le dit
nous sommes face à des sauts
technologiques spectaculaires qui sont
de plus en plus brutaux et donc coûteux
l'espace les fonds sous-marins le cyber
sont des lieux nouveaux de
conflictualité et de militarisation
cette programmation militaire nous
permettra de répondre à ces nouveaux
enjeux 413 milliards d'euros pour
moderniser nos armées ça peut paraître
nécessaire vu le contexte international
mais ça interroge quand même certains vu
le contexte de la mobilisation sociale
contre la réforme des retraites qui
prévoit d'économiser à peine une dizaine
de milliards d'euros écoutez le
coordinateur de la France ins manuel bon
par hier sur ce plateau quand on veut
aller chercher des ressources
financières on est en capacité de le
faire donc les arguments qui consistent
à dire on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite
parce que sinon c'est la faillite la
ruine monsieur du stop t'avait dit ça à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde doit
se rendre compte à ce moment-là que
c'est ces arguments sont des arguments
complètement loufoques pour le reste nos
armées notre capacité de défense elle
doit avoir des moyens financiers pour
qu'on soit en capacité de se défendre
tout simplement et voilà sur le fond on
sent bien que cette loi de programmation
militaire a priori ne déclenche pas
d'hostilité de la part des oppositions
de notre porte-avion nucléaire ah oui
c'est le successeur de notre porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle Sébastien Lecornu
l'annonce ce sera une cathédrale de
technologie et de compétences le poids
de ce nouveau porte-avions 75000 tonnes
il abritera 2000 marins avec deux mini
centrales nucléaires à son bord son coup
à 10 milliards d'euros et sa
construction se fera sur la période 2026
2037 racheté mal d'abord un mot sur la
forme sur le calendrier est-ce que c'est
pas un peu étrange pour le gouvernement
d'annoncer à 413 milliards d'euros de
dépenses pour nos armées alors qu'ils
demandent aux Français de travailler
deux ans de plus pour économiser à peine
10 milliards d'euros
moi je suis peut-être plus cohérent que
le gouvernement puisque moi je suis
contre le reclus de 65 ans il aurait pu
d'ailleurs vous aurez pu parler plutôt
de la suppression l'ISF qui là pour le
coup aurait permis de financer ce qu'on
nous annonce comme déficit des retraites
donc le sujet des femmes moi je crois
pas qu'on doit opposer on doit opposer
entre la question sociale et la question
militaire je crois que les deux sont
importants mais avant de dire un chiffre
ce que vous l'avez dit 413 c'est très
bien mais la question d'abord il y a une
question de méthode sur comment on
construit une stratégie depuis la
dernière loi de programmation militaire
quelques éléments vous avez vu un pays
membres de conseil de sécurité de
Nations Unies qui allait arme nucléaire
qui s'appelle la Russie décide de passer
des frontières d'attaquer un autre pays
qui s'appelle la Russie la Russie pour
l'Ukraine et sur le crâne en Europe il y
a depuis notre situation en Afrique
c'était largement détérioré pour être
poli il y a depuis une compétition qui
devient qui a passé un son de cap entre
la Chine et et les États-Unis l'alliance
Chine Russie qui est en train de se
forger et la Chine qui dit moi j'ai un
nouveau modèle de société qui est posé
je trouve que quand vous ne serait-ce
que cela je pourrais ajouter la liste
pour être encore long je crois que le
gouvernement aurait gagné je l'ai dit au
ministre lors de du budget en séance ici
ouais gagner à avoir un travail de
réflexion stratégique qui ne soit pas
seulement en chambre par le gouvernement
ses services mais aussi avec le
Parlement je crois que ça c'est un débat
parce que si en fonction de cela de ce
que vous imaginez pour l'avenir que vous
construisez une armée que vous
construisez des moyens parce que ceux
qui ont pensé à l'époque et je pouvais
je peux entendre cela que la fin de
l'Union soviétique c'était la fin de
l'histoire c'était les dividendes de la
paix on voit bien que 20 30 ans 40 50
ans après ce n'est pas la réalité donc
je pense ça c'est le premier sujet et je
crois que ça c'est ça peut être un biais
un travers dans cette loi là on va
regarder puisque on nous a donné des
chiffres on va regarder maintenant dans
le dossier ça c'est le premier aspect
vous avez raison de rappeler également
que sur la partie inflation
carburant etc il y a des coûts
supplémentaires mais ça c'est normal bon
à part cela on va causer c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui se dire que il faut
travailler sur d'abord maintenir les
capacités à français c'est important
mais il faut aussi imaginer de demain
parce que nos ennemis continuent à se
développer il y a la guerre officielle
qu'on connaît sur Internet opérations
mais comme la dynisme il y a plein
d'autres défis qu'on ne voit pas au
quotidien et donc moi je crois qu'il est
important effectivement notre pays soit
doté parce que nous sommes la seule
armée globale en Europe sur l'Union
européenne avec notamment en termes
d'armée conventionnelle et de dissuasion
nucléaire moi je suis très pour le
maintien le renforcement et la
modernisation de l'outil de saison
nucléaire parce que c'est comme ça aussi
qu'on protège les Français dire cela
c'est la protection et moi je salue
encore une fois les forces armées qui
ici sur le territoire mais aussi en
opération défendent parfois meurt même
mais pour défendre à la fois d'autres
pays j'ai envie de dire l'Union
européenne et puis nos et puis notre
démocratie donc il y a un véritable
besoin de sauvegarder cette dissuasion
nucléaire française qui est un
savoir-faire un atout moi je dis plus il
faut la moderniser il faut en permanence
parce que parce que d'abord il faut il
faut s'assurer la guerre en Ukraine on
se rend compte que sur quand il faut
aider l'Ukraine tous les pays européens
qui donnent des armes il n'a pas assez
donc se la question également d'une
filière industrielle qui existe et qui
est performante en France il faut la
renforcer mais de se dire comment à tout
moment on passe on passe à renforcement
des capacités et donc nos concurrents
cherchent toujours des arts nouvelle
donc nous on doit également être
là-dedans dans ce débat là parce que
sinon nous aurons quand vous êtes moins
j'ai envie de dire moins dans la
dissuasion vous êtes moins craint par
les autres pays alors vous êtes en
danger sur la science international et
de la France et l'Europe est en sont en
danger et donc ce nouveau porte-avion ce
nouveau porte-avions ultra moderne qui
va remplacer le Charles de Gaulle c'est
une bonne idée moi j'ai toujours été
pour un porte-avion après faisons
attention de ne pas apparaître comme le
côté gadget parce que il y a aussi un
sujet il faut que les Français entendent
que la guerre ce n'est pas un joystick
ce n'est pas il y a 15 ans dans une
salle et qui tire de loin il y a la
guerre il faut l'entendre c'est des
morts c'est de la destruction et donc il
faut toujours préparer la guerre pour
avoir la paix je crois qu'il faut
l'avoir en tête et c'est vrai que moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est pas le côté gadget
c'est la capacité aujourd'hui qu'on a ou
pas et je dans la parce que la première
enveloppe qui a aujourd'hui dans ce que
nous annonce encore une fois nous
verrons le texte c'est la capacité de
maintien du matériel existant ouais bien
donc il y a toujours ce problème là à la
fin c'est du matériel et des hommes et
des femmes qui ont des poids ou qu'on
dépend pas sur le territoire je crois
qu'il faut avoir cette responsabilité là
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains moi je serai le chef de fil
et on aura on verra bien évidemment à ce
que nous soyons sur ces questions là
comme si nous étions responsabilité
parce que nous entendons revenir aux
responsabilités bien avant la fin de
cette la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire et je crois qu'il faut
effectivement qu'on soit en capacité de
maintien la sécurité de nos territoires
que ce soit l'Hexagone également
d'outre-mer parce que j'ai fait avec
d'autres collègues un rapport sur un dos
Pacifique on voit bien qu'il y a aussi
un danger sur effectivement l'outre-mer
notamment si on prend la Réunion
d'académie ou la poésie et donc il faut
maintenir des capacités et là-bas il
faut même les renforcer et j'ai vu que
il y avait un projet de renforcement
dans la programmation militaire et c'est
une bonne chose
merci Alex merci regarde à tout à
l'heure on parlera de la fin de vie tout
à l'heure Alex on va parler du Parti
socialiste législatif partielle en
Ariège qui est une résonance nationale
la candidate dissidente socialiste a
battu la députée sortante de la France
insoumise qui était soutenu par la nuque
et soutenu par la direction du Parti
socialiste c'est une fracturation de la
nuque d'abord est-ce qu'on peut se dire
que grâce à Martine Froget le RN n'est
pas second tour l'extrême bon n'est pas
au second tour contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé précédemment je crois qu'on
peut d'abord s'en satisfaire grâce à
Martine Froget on peut se dire que la
candidate du pouvoir en place de
Renaissance au moins il y a les
retraites a été battue également et que
ces deux candidatures là ont baissé le
nombre de voix ça je crois que c'est
d'abord on peut on peut s'en féliciter
dans ce que j'entends dans ce que je
vois ce que je lis ça c'est le la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que moi je suis toujours heureux qu'une
camarade socialiste en espèces Martine
projet soit lui socialiser ce que j'ai
dit dimanche soir c'est que moi je suis
heureux que la famille socialiste au
Parlement s'agrandisse avec son élection
et pour ça
parce que quand on lit les communiquer
de la direction du Parti socialiste on a
pas l'impression qu'elle soit
spécialiste
Martine frog tout son engagement
personnel politique et socialiste si les
camarades de l'Ariège à qui je fais
confiance tous les camarades se disent
de l'Ariège ont soutenu depuis le début
de sa candidature on fait campagne pour
elle je pense à mes amis Kamel Chebli ou
Carol Delga beaucoup d'autres également
Jean-Luc Michaud questemateur ici il y
avait à nos côtés tous ces gens-là ont
fait campagne sont des socialistes elle
est socialistes les socialistes
socialiste après j'invite d'abord tous
mes camarades à se calmer sur les
réseaux sociaux à se calmer nous sommes
tous socialistes c'est une famille on
peut avoir des divergences d'une famille
mais on n'est pas obligé de d'étaler ça
et avec ces mots que j'ai pu lire ou
entendre donc communiquer de presse mais
d'autres en face également donc moi par
exemple c'est la candidate d'une
alliance des droites et ce n'est pas
vrai
ce n'est pas vrai
n'est pas et là aussi on n'est pas
obligé de tomber dans les panneaux je me
suis du socle que Monsieur ouzil ouzoule
ou que Monsieur ou que Monsieur Raffarin
il a faillite on n'est pas obligé de
tomber dans le panneau elle est contre
la forme des retraites elle est contre
souvent là elle est socialiste voilà moi
je suis heureux qui encore une fois
l'extrême droite et là et la droite dans
tous ses composantes étaient battus et
qu'elle soit lu socialiste au Parlement
de place le chef de fil de la France
insoumise il dénonce une coalition
contre sa candidate et il appelle le
Parti socialiste a clarifié sa ligne on
écoute
j'observe que ceux qui saluent
aujourd'hui l'élection de Madame projet
sont vont même de Monsieur dussobe
jusqu'à monsieur Odoul qui est
porte-parole du rassemblement national
donc voilà je pense qu'il y a une forme
de coalition de circonstances pour
essayer de battre la candidate de la
nups et je le regrette je pense que le
Parti socialiste doit dire clairement
quel est son orientation soit le parti
socialiste et en faveur de la nupes que
je souhaite puisque je suis attaché à
cette à cette alliance soit le parti
socialiste ne le souhaite pas mais vous
pouvez pas avoir dans la même
organisation politique deux orientations
comme ça qui se confrontent
la première chose c'est que son
prédécesseur
monsieur katnas en juin 2022 le 6 juin
j'ai bien lu la presse appelé les
électeurs durable à voter pour la nups
est-ce que Monsieur catenins était
l'objet d'une coalition je ne sais quoi
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer sérieusement
que le scrutin une image au second avec
les deux tours en France fait qu'au
premier tour c'est que la gauche qui
vote pour vous et surtout il y a que la
gauche qui va pour vous et monsieur mon
père comme tous les autres
parlementaires ont aussi des voix qui ne
viennent pas leur formation poétique ça
c'est le deuxième point et le troisième
point j'ai bien compris que chez
Monsieur Bompard il n'y avait pas à les
filles il n'y avait pas de congrès pas
de débat démocratique mais il faut qu'il
entendent que notre relation partialiste
dans la relation démocratique qui a eu
un vote et il s'avère que grosso modo 55
ans il y a deux lignes qui sont au
parcelistes qui vont cohabiter et ce
n'est pas monsieur Bompard d'expliquer
qu'il faudrait que certains soient des
bons socialistes et même moi franchement
j'ai pas le soir se voir et les
camarades n'ont pas le soir se voir ni
de socialisme ni de gauche de mon part
ou de quiconque
nous attendons pas de brevet les
socialistes sur les territoires comme au
Parlement portent des valeurs depuis
1905 la création du partialiste et non
pas attendu monsieur bon pas où et les
filles pour dire qu'ils étaient vraiment
debout je sais pas vraiment nous sommes
de gauche nous avons les valeurs de
gauche nous avons un projet de gauche
nous combattons la droite et l'extrême
droite et ce qui s'est passé avec
Martine projet c'est qu'elle a permis la
défaite de la droite et de l'extrême
droite dans cette élection-là et elle
est aujourd'hui députée est-ce que c'est
aussi un message à Olivier Faure le
résultat de cette élection est-ce qu'il
est fragilité
est-ce que je crois enfin c'est pas le
sujet vous dites socialiste et vous avez
le prochain secrétaire du Parti
socialiste pour elle c'est son droit
c'est son choix moi j'ai voté dans mon
année conscience en entendant le premier
fédéral mon homologue de la dernière au
Conseil national nous expliqua situation
je lui fais confiance j'ai entendu à
présent de région je lui fais confiance
la prison département je lui fais
confiance je ne fais confiance
mais la question qui est posée pour les
français très honnêtement c'est pas
est-ce que Madame Froget va ou je sais
pas quoi ou monsieur je ne sais quoi ou
racheter mal je ne sais qui la question
c'est est-ce que vous les socialistes
vous êtes capable de répondre à des
questions assez simple comment je fais
pour bouffer après le 15 du mois comment
je fais pour me dire que l'école de mes
enfants vous êtes avoir pour que l'école
permette à mes enfants d'avoir un bon
métier demain comment je fais pour que
les gens sortent en toute sécurité
comment je fais pour me dire que la
guerre en Ukraine n'aura pas de
conséquences ici et je pourrais
développer les ondes c'est ça que les
Français ont des socialistes pas leurs
bagarres mais leur réponse et leur
solution merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invitée ce matin dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
on reviendra sur la question de la fin
de vie on en a parlé avec vous les
manuel Macron qui a donc reçu les
conclusions des travaux de la convention
citoyenne et promener un projet de loi
d'ici la fin de l'été on va en débattre
d'abord vous l'avez dit on a que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
pupendiculaire qui nous rejoint